- [Voiceover] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
non-commercial use only.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to a conversation
with history, I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is John Witte,
who is the Jonas Robitscher
professor of law, the Alonzo
L. McDonald distinguished
professor and director of the
Center for the Study of Law
and Religion at Emory Law
School at Emory University.
He is the 2011 Jefferson
lecturer on the Berkeley campus.
John, welcome to our program.
- Thank you very much,
it's good to be here.
- Where did you go to college
and what was your major in?
- I followed the natural path
for a Dutch immigrant boy
which was to go to Calvin College
in Grand Rapids, Michigan.
It was the college of the
Christian Reformed Church,
of which I was member.
I was there, my world opened
up rapidly when I got there.
That was a big city, that was
a big intellectual environment
and I studied biology,
history, and philosophy.
I simply couldn't settle on
one, and so I was a pre-med,
a pre-law, and a
pre-graduate school student.
And it was a small enough
college where you could
do all three without
being too much of a fool.
- And what helped you sort that out?
A lot of different paths
that you could've taken.
- I was inspired by teachers
in all three of those fields,
and I ultimately did the MCAT,
the LSAT and the GRE, and
applied for law school, medical
school and graduate school.
Got into all three, and
then couldn't decide.
And what ultimately helped
me decide was I wrote to
this wonderful professor
at Harvard Law School
called Harold J. Berman,
whose work I had read
a great deal in my undergraduate days.
He had been writing on
issues of Soviet law,
but also law and religion
in Western history.
And I found his work deeply
satisfying intellectually.
And I just took, as a 21 year
old punk out of Calvin College
the whim of writing him and
asking him for his advice.
And he gave me a long two
page letter back, and the core
of his advice was come study
with me, and we can work
together on issues of law and
religion in Western history.
That was the key for me, and
I went to sit at his feet.
- And so it was Harvard
Law School, and there,
was there a kind of a focus
that immediately attracted you,
this kind of, obviously you ended up with
law and religion as a very great interest.
- Yeah, I spent, all law
students have their fist year
prescribed, and during that
first year of law school courses
I spent 40 hours at work
working with Berman.
It was a little grueling,
but it was a wonderful
opportunity to be released
into the treasure room
of the Harvard Law Library
and read all these fabulous
tracts of the 14th
through the 18th century
focusing on different aspects of
law and religion in Western history.
Throughout my second and third
year, I continued to work
with Berman, I took elective
courses in the grad school,
the divinity school as
well as the law school.
You don't specialize in law
school, but I tended to focus on
courses that looked at
issues of legal history,
legal philosophy,
interdisciplinary approaches to law
which were just beginning to
bubble at Harvard Law School
at the time, with critical
legal studies especially.
And I had a chance to
just smell the flowers
in a number of different
fields, and convince myself that
the stuff I was doing a-vocationally
as a research assistant
with Berman was really front and center
of what I wanted to do professionally.
- And the important new path here is
really history, and
the history of the law.
Not just being a lawyer.
- Not just being a lawyer,
I couldn't see myself
as being a conventional
lawyer and practicing in
public or private or public interest work.
I would do that if it was
necessary for five or 10 years
to cultivate a traditional
specialty and then hold that out
alongside my passionate interest in
law and religion and legal history.
But I really didn't see myself
actually practicing law.
What I wanted to do was
to be a legal scholar.
And one of the things
that Professor Berman
pushed me to do was to
write, and to write early.
He co-authored a couple
of articles with me
while I was a law student, and
then really turned me loose
and pushed me hard to
get into writing myself.
And so I followed none of
the conventional routes.
I didn't do law review,
I didn't do moot court,
I didn't do federal
clerkships, I just worked with
Berman 40 hours a week,
and I wrote up a storm
while I was a law student,
and that got me started
rather quickly as a law professor.
- And as you talk about your background,
there seems to be an
interesting dynamic between
what you're calling a
provincial background,
within kind of a closed
community, but really
opening up to a cosmopolitan
world, and then focusing on
this interface between
the law and religion,
which is key to that interface.
- Yeah, it was really
interesting to move from this
tiny cultural cocoon in
St. Catharines, Ontario,
to what I considered to be
the big city of Calvin College
in Grand Rapids, Michigan,
and then to go from there
to Harvard Law School,
where in many ways you had
a platform to look at the world.
And to have the chance to
interact with fellow students
from all different walks
of life and all different
parts of the world, to be
able to interact with ideas
in the Western tradition but
also well beyond the Western
tradition, to have a chance
to look both historically and
along very very wide public
policy grids at some of the
fundamental questions of
faith, of freedom, of family,
and other things that captivated me.
Convinced me that binocular
of law and religion that
Berman was giving me the
opportunity to look through,
and to think about how these
two great universal solvents
of human living have worked
historically, how they work
today, how in many ways they
provide the biggest challenges
for us historically and today,
that was a captivating way
to think about the world anew.
And it was an unpopular way
of thinking about the world
in the 1980s when I was a law
student, people didn't really
think about religion as a
category of legal study.
Most people still were working
under the Enlightenment
assumption that religion was superstition,
it was the opiate of the masses,
it was something that would
happily die a quiet death
as scientific rationalism
took over, and technology
would replace the priesthood
as the leaders of our society and culture.
And at the time, making an
argument to say that religion
actually is an important
source of Western law,
that religious dimensions of
law are actually important
to take into account, that
religious legal systems are
really part of our cultural
identity and civilization
and we have to take them
seriously, that at the time was
controversial, but I felt
in part by reason of my own
upbringing in a conservative
Christian community and in part
by looking by analogy into
Jewish and Muslim communities,
could see this was something
that we needed to do.
And I thought Berman was
remarkably prescient and courageous
at the time, to be pressing this as
a fundamental part of legal education,
and happily we were
vindicated in that over time.
- So you were coming...
To your education just at a time
when there was intellectual ferment.
Let's talk a little about that,
because the reigning notion
had been, well, law is an
isolated set of studies,
and that it's really, you quote Holmes
in one of your articles,
it's really from experience
that we get the law, it's
not from a natural law
or from any other sectors of society.
- Yeah, legal education
from the 1920s to the 1970s,
in North America at least,
was intensely positivistic
in the sense of law is
really its own science,
it's an autonomous science.
What we're looking for is the
instruments, the techniques
of law, and how law emerges,
to what extent it's influenced
by or has influence on
other dimensions of life,
to what extent we wanna take into account
any other institutions besides the state
and the operation of law were all
considered to be taboo subjects.
In the late 1960s and 70s, there was
the rise of interdisciplinary legal study.
Some of that on the back
of legal realism that had
challenged this notion of
autonomous legal reasoning,
but a lot of it with the rise
of recognizing that holistic
understandings of knowledge
had to also apply to law.
That law properly had to
be understood in concert,
in conversation with other
disciplines, and we were just
beginning to see interdisciplinary
legal study emerging.
Law in economics was a first one,
law in politics a second,
law in literature a third.
These were suddenly new
areas of interdisciplinary
discourse that were
beginning to be accepted into
legal education, and began to fracture
the traditional legal positivism paradigm.
The law and religion movement
that Berman and others
were starting in the 1970s
built on the momentum of that
interdisciplinary legal
studies movement all together.
- And what was going on
in society, in your mind,
that accounts for this change of thinking?
'Cause one always wonders,
what makes for intellectual
ferment, for new paradigms,
new ways of looking at things.
- Yeah, it's the good
political scientist's question,
of course.
I think one was simply the
exhaustion of the legal
positivist paradigm as just
methodologically impossible
to maintain, and the
recognition that these doctrines
don't just sit, they're
not just isolated icons,
they have to really be
thought about in context.
Part of it was the Marxist critique of law
that began to challenge
some of the economic
and sociological assumptions
that were being made
in legislation and litigation.
Some of it was a kinda new
approach of psychologists
and anthropologists who
began to look at law as
very much part of a cultural
and civilizational fabric.
Part of it was feminist
critiques of law that began to
challenge a lot of the
patriarchal assumptions that were
explicit or latent in legal institutions.
And I think part of it
was simply the new wholism
that was beginning to
emerge in epistemology.
Where people were beginning to say, look,
in order to understand
life, in order to understand
a big institution like law,
or religion, or the economy,
or things of comparable
heft, we really needed
to have a kaleidoscopic methodology.
And I think all of those
converged together in higher legal
education to force people to
try to develop new paradigms.
And interdisciplinary legal studies was
the beneficiary of that
in the 1970s and 80s.
- What is the skillset involved
in the kind of work that you do?
Obviously a knowledge
of the law, but this,
you clearly come to the
profession at a time when
interdisciplinary skills are
very important, and it would
also seem that comparative
skills are very important.
It's not just what's happening in
Christianity or Judaism, but also Islam.
- Yeah.
You have to remember,
interdisciplinary legal
study is about legal study.
And first an foremost what we're doing for
people coming through a
law and religion focus
is to prepare them to be lawyers.
In any walk of life, in any
profession or any institutional
structure, they've gotta learn
the basic black letter rules
and tools of contracts and torts
and property and constitutional law.
They have to learn the
basic methods and matters of
legal science, methods of
reasoning, methods of evidence
collecting, methods of building
and breaking down arguments.
They have to understand
that they're part of
a long tradition, and understand what
precedent means and how to apply it.
There's no substitute for
that in any interdisciplinary
legal approach; that betrays
those fundamentals of the
profession, really in many
ways betrays itself over time.
So what we do is we add a
dimension to education that says
that religion has been an
important historical source
for many of our legal ideas,
for better or for worse,
that religion is a dimension
of life that has to be taken
into account when you look
at how a legal institution
or system as a whole
operates, and that religious
communities themselves have legal systems.
Halakhah within Judaism, Sharia
within Islam, canon law in
Ecclesiastical discipline
within Christianity,
and that these are massive
non-profit organizations,
global in their sweep, that
have internal mechanisms
of law that have to be understood.
And that we have to understand
the relationship between them
and state law, we have to
understand the religious freedom
claims that those
individuals and groups make
on the strength of their
religious convictions
and religious institutional apparatus,
and we have to understand
how to broker the inevitable
tensions one has between
different religious communities'
understandings of law, or
their own particular religious
legal system, with each
other and with the state.
And then I think finally, the
real question is trying to
sensitize people to the
reality that law and religion
is simply one example of
interdisciplinary legal study.
And to do this right, like to
do legal education in general
right, you have to have very
strong peripheral vision.
You have to understand law and economics,
you have to understand law and sociology,
law and politics, law and literature.
The best lawyer who's
trained is always trained
at least to have very very
powerful peripheral vision.
That even if he or she is
specialized in a given area of law
like law and religion, they
have to be sensitive to and
have enough peripheral
vision to understand
what's there on the
outside of your discipline.
Law is a big universal
solvent of human living,
law is a huge science
that has to be mastered,
and even if you specialize,
you've gotta have
enough sense of when you don't know.
- You refer at one point in
one of your essays to kind of a
binocular vision when it
comes to understanding
the interface between law and religion.
Talk about that, because
the trajectory in the past
was to focus on one or
to focus on the other.
- Well part of it's it's
just a clever image to try to
get people to recognize
that when you're looking at,
especially an historical
phenomenon or a movement,
say the 16th century
Protestant reformation.
You can't just look at that
through theology or through
doctrine or through liturgy,
you can't just look at that
as the time of the reception of Roman law,
or the transformation of the Roman empire,
the Holy Roman Empire, or the
rise of the legal profession.
In many ways what you want,
what you're interested in
is taking a binocular vision
of that movement, of that
period, and saying, how do
these two feed each other?
In many ways it's a
species of the question
you asked me a few minutes ago,
what caused the change
in the 1970s and 80s
toward interdisciplinary legal study.
This is a spin on that question which is,
to what extent if you put
law and theology together,
if you look at this
through the lenses of both
the professional legal
historian and the professional
church historian, what do
you see in the 16th century
that's distinctive and how
do they feed each other?
It's that image that I acquired
initially as an historian
that I'm trying now to
train on modern questions,
questions of family, for
example, family being
both a legal and a spiritual institution.
Issues of education, which
in many case has both
religious and secular dimensions,
issues of charity and the like.
So in many ways it's an attempt to say,
rather than simply
training one methodology,
one set of institutional
concerns, one set of professional
aspirations on a given topic
or theme, let's try to bring
the two together into an interesting
widening of the perspective
that's offered by that.
- I'm curious in terms of
being a historian of a faith,
and if one actually believes in the faith,
what is that tension like,
because the law in history
is finding the truth by
rigorous standards and
searching for objectivity,
but on the other hand,
a person of faith is a believer,
but somehow I get the sense
from your work that this tension really is
helpful in probing what
happened in the religion,
and understanding the dynamic by which
this is brought into the legal system.
- That's a big question and we
could be here a little while.
First of all, objective historiography is
a wonderful thing to do in the classroom,
but it's not really
easy to do in practice.
So people bring their
blinders, people bring their
prejudices and preferences,
and that's simply
part of the epistemology
of being an historian.
Secondly I would say I'm not
an historian of a particular
Christian community or a
particular tradition of thought,
I'm really a historian of the West.
I happen to study the two
millennia of the common era,
sometimes dipping into
ancient Greek and Hebrew
and Roman texts, and
increasingly as I've gotten
a bit older, trying to
look beyond the West
for analogy for competing perspectives,
for different ways of
thinking about things.
I'm interested in this
in part as a person of
religious faith who wants to
find a way of reconstructing
some of the wisdom of
my particular tradition
of Christianity, and making it applicable
to a modern, pluralistic world.
Where there is no longer an
assumption of a Christian
magistrate, when there's
no longer an assumption of
an established religion, and
when there's intense pluralism
and people's argument from
faith or from a canon or from
a tradition simply the
start rather than the end
of a conversation, that
in many ways developing
the rational logic to make
this wisdom of the tradition
applicable and useful to
wider pluralistic society.
So part of my exercise is that.
Part of my exercise is
that of an historian,
historian of law, excuse me, to say,
I'm interested in seeing
what precedent is useful
and what precedent needs to be discarded.
Jaroslav Pelikan, the great
Yale church historian,
now alas a blessed
memory, has this notion of
tradition is the living faith of the dead,
traditionalism is the
dead faith of the living.
And I like the idea of traditions
being something that grows.
Understanding where we came from,
understanding where we're going,
and trying to find the
mechanisms, the methodologies,
the responsible ways of
moving the growing end
of tradition to accommodate new realities,
to purge injustices of the past.
So both of those exercises are
going on simultaneously in my mind.
I don't pretend that I'm
objective, but what's interesting
to me personally as I walked
through this last 25 years
is that, and as a little boy
in St. Catharines, Ontario
with a very very small Christian cocoon,
of a Dutch Calvinist
variety in particular,
and having the privilege
to grow in humility
as you look across the
world and you look at
all these fabulous ideas
and institutions that are
out there and to see all these different
faith communities and how they operate.
And it reminds me, and I'll
stop at this, it reminds me of
this wonderful adage that
Martin Marty, the great
church historian at University of Chicago
has playing with this movie theme.
It takes a thief to catch a
thief, and his flip on that is
it takes a person of deep
religious conviction to
appreciate the deep religious
conviction of another.
You'll learn by analogy, and
you appreciate, tolerate,
respect the rights, evidence,
support the existence
of the other, just because
by analogy you can see
what they're doing and
why they're doing it.
That's kind of been what's
interesting for me as I've
kind of toured Judaism, Islam,
and dabbled a bit in other
faith traditions and their
influence upon law and culture.
- One of the conclusions
that I think you've come to
as I read some of your essays
is really that there is
a lot of commonalities in
the law and in religion,
that these are two
domains that in some sense
mirror each other, there are a lot of
similarities that have evolved over time.
- Yeah, I mean we share certain concepts.
Covenant and contract,
justice and righteousness,
we share certain institutions,
take marriage, take
education, take charity.
We share a number of methods,
how to parse the text,
how to build a tradition,
how to create a canon,
how to reason responsibly
from text and tradition
to modern prescription or principle.
We share a lot of
institutional structures.
Religious communities are
organized as corporate entities
in many ways, and have government
structures that sometimes
are analogous to that which
prevails in the state.
Historically sometimes these
overlap, they were the same,
today they're often differentiated.
And so what I'm interested in is kinda
looking at that creative interplay,
and then taking again the binocular angle.
In many ways when we're talking about
an agreement that we have together,
from a religious side it's a covenant,
from a legal side it's a contract,
and what's interesting is the
convergence between those two
where the overlapping consensus and
the creative tension between those two.
We talk about redemption
and rehabilitation
as ways of moving beyond
a point of conflict
and coming back into community.
From a religious side, this
has some really interesting
liturgical and other
institutional and psychological
elements, on a legal side
there's a lot of methodology
in that, and institutional
responsibility that follows.
So part of what I'm interested
in is to look at those
binaries, especially where
there's creative tension.
- I would be curious 'cause
you seem to be well-positioned
to give us some insights on
this, what does creativity
look like in the law, and
what does creativity look like
in religion itself, the
practice of religion?
Can they be compared at all?
- That's an interesting question.
Well we're both working out of traditions.
We both presuppose
precedent and we all make,
we both make changes only when we overcome
the presumption of the null hypothesis.
There has to be strong
argument to make change.
So creativity is in part a creature of
what we're faced with in a society.
Law works, theology works,
religious communities work
with the contingencies of where they live.
I'd say secondly there's,
inspiration works
in both these traditions
in different ways.
Religious communities talk
about divine inspiration,
or inspiration from the heart,
but legal communities talk the same way.
We have transcendent ideals, we have
transcendent values that
we seek to aspire to.
What is liberty, what is
due process of law, what are
some of these fundamentals
that we take for granted?
These are transcendent ideals
that inspire certain change
over time and induce creative change.
I think third we also sometimes
face common calamities.
The Holocaust, the World War, a tsunami.
The blight of terrorism,
a nuclear holocaust.
All of which face us today.
And those demand sometimes
serious institutional
and intellectual changes in
our particular communities
and we sometimes will work together
as religious and political
communities to respond to those.
It's not a good answer, it's a question
I'm gonna have to ponder.
- No, it was more than satisfactory.
I know that in your work,
you've done a lot of work on
looking at the way
religion impacted the law,
changed the law, that it was the religious
individuals and groups who
in practicing their religion
sought freedom, sought the
right to speak, sought the right
to pray, to association, and
sort of built the foundation
that a lot of what we understand as the
Western human rights, that
that definition came about.
Talk a little about that,
because that interface really
becomes important in
understanding how the law emerged
and how it should relate
to other religions.
- It's a hard question, that's a shifting,
you're moving into a shifting field
of the history of human rights.
Our schoolboy and schoolgirl
logic in textbooks always
taught us that human
rights are a product of the
Enlightenment, they are the
final celebration of reason
over religion, the celebration
of the individual over
community, the celebration
of the sovereignty of the
individual over the sovereignty of god,
and we've now finally
broken the shackles of
religious establishment and
created human rights for all.
Now that's a wonderful schoolboy
logic that many of us grew up with.
The reality is that historically
it's complete nonsense.
It's an interesting anecdote,
but an important one,
to say that by 1650,
1650, 150 years before
the Bill of Rights was passed,
every one of the rights
set forth in the Bill of
Rights had already been
defined, defended, and died for
by Protestants and by Catholics.
Forged out of great struggle,
oftentimes responses to
the ardor of persecution, of
pogroms, of religious warfare,
but a recognition over time
through cruel experience
that there are certain
features of human nature,
certain features that we share with all
brothers and sisters on this earth,
that really have to be
respected by the state.
What that anecdote tries
to illustrate is that
rights talk is not something that is
a creature of the
Enlightenment, number one.
Rights talk is also not
something which is a creature
of the West, or a creature
of Western Christianity.
In many ways, rights are
fundamental goods of human nature.
Fundamental gifts that we've
all been given, that have
evolved over time or been
imbued in us through a creator
or through a creative
process, depending on how
you want to deal with human anthropology.
And that the West, sometimes
through hard and cruel
experience, began to discover
these rights of human nature,
and began to think about how to
implement them in serious ways.
And oftentimes were forced
to implement them and
fight for them in serious
ways when they were
fundamentally betrayed by tyranny,
by warfare, by persecution, by pogrom.
And that we can find, if you
look at the history of the West
we can find rights talk
already in the Hebrew Bible,
in some of the early Roman law
texts and medieval canon law
and early modern civil law and common law.
And in many ways the
Enlightenment is living off of
the capital of the intellectual
discovery and institutional
implementation of rights
that the West had,
through long and hard
process, come to discover.
And why that's important for discussion of
universal human rights in the
20th and 21st century is that
what human rights instruments today become
for other communities, are
simply mirrors in which
they can reflect upon
their own civilization
and cultural and religious experience.
And invitations for them
to go back to their texts,
their canons, their original
ideas, their great prophets,
some of them slaughtered for
their courageous advocacy.
And to begin to see, in their
own religious traditions
and civilizational patterns,
what are the teachings
and practices, norms and
habits that are most conducive
to what we in the West now in the
20th century have called human rights.
And the interesting thing that's going on,
and one of your prior guests,
a dear friend and colleague
Abdullahi An-Na'im calls a
hermeneutic of human rights
that's beginning to emerge in
different parts of the world.
With Judaism, Islam, Hinduism, Buddhism,
Confucianism, Daoism, even
traditional communities
beginning to use this human
rights as mirror image,
to begin to look back at their traditions,
to reclaim their own voices in
the human rights discussions.
And then, to criticize
some of the formulations of
human rights that we have as
purported universal statements
after World War II, and to
begin to make particular claims
to their unique understandings
of what human nature
demands and needs in the 21st century.
- So building this edifice
of a lawful society
where religion is respected,
it involves hard work.
It's a navigation that requires
both the law and society
to change on the one
hand, but also religions,
you're suggesting, to think
about their own history
and their own set of values
in light of what you call
the mirror of human rights, hard work.
- It is hard work, and
a cruel work sometimes,
and oftentimes is induced
or catalyzed by the sudden,
then traumatic absence, or
betrayal of fundamental rights.
What happens when you blow
up 100 thousand people?
What happens when you
see tens of thousands
of people dying from
famine or treatable disease
when there's food rotting
in the storage sheds?
What happens when you
have massive atrocities,
alas as we've seen in
Chile and southeast Asia
and Rwanda, Burundi, into
Chechnya and elsewhere.
There we're beginning to see,
we viscerally react against
that in part because it
violates our very human nature
to see brothers and sisters in
different parts of the world
so trampled in their human existence.
And what it induces, and
the hard work it causes,
is to get the local communities
to begin to process,
painful as it is, to claim,
what are the grounds on which
we can properly treat
the other, and what are,
on those grounds, the
violations that have to be,
what are the violations that
have to be both advertised,
indicted, and then ultimately
pursued for remedy?
And I think what's
happening, interestingly,
in different parts of the world today,
see the democratic revolutions
in the Mediterranean basin
and North Africa all the
way up to Libya, Yemen and
elsewhere, from Libya to
Yemen and Biran and elsewhere
is that each of these
communities is going through
this hard experience now
through revolutionary fervor.
Some of them are prepared,
some of them are not prepared,
to accept the human rights
that they're advocating.
What's important, especially
for our Muslim brothers and
sisters around the world, is
to recognize that the West
did not create rights,
western Christian paths to
discovering rights are not translatable
into other religious communities.
And western formulations,
constitutional formulations
of rights, are not exportable
entities that simply can be
put in place in these communities
as the be all and end all.
Every community has to
discover for itself,
every religious tradition
has to discover for itself,
the resources it has to
put in place the rights
that ultimately are going to respect
the fundamentals of human nature.
And that's gonna be a creaky, a painful,
an arduous, sometimes a
centuries-long process,
as it was in the West, but every community
I think eventually will get there.
- Help us understand
what this work involves.
In a way, in a particular religion,
it seems to be in part
a struggle over power.
Who will define what our tradition is.
Which text will we look to.
What is the interpretation of those texts.
So this is kind of the
work that takes time,
it takes argument, and
it takes persuasion,
but it can also be a bloody conflict
within any particular religion.
- Sure.
And you put your finger
right on the hardest part
at the beginning, which is the power.
Those who hold the power
are not interested in
changing institutional structures
that have propped them up in that power.
And oftentimes it takes
not just persuasion,
but serious pressure and
sometimes revolutionary fervor,
and outright revolution and
warfare, to remove our brokers
that stand in the way of
the realization of rights.
Whether they're religious
or political or cultural or
tribal leaders, these folk
are not gonna give up easily.
And a mere argument out of
John Locke's two treatises
on government is not gonna convince them.
And a mere argument to say,
but it's gonna be good for your
people, and think of what's
gonna happen to them once you
give them their full human
rights is not gonna work either.
It takes violence, unfortunately.
Violence is a necessary,
or at least an essential
and sometimes a necessary condition
for the move toward democratic government
and human rights
vindication on the ground.
And one virtue we have in a
21st century globalized world
with its transparent media
is that it's not so easy
for tyrants to continue to sit
without accountability to the world.
And so one of the things
that human rights does,
and international diplomacy,
and forgive me for treading on
your own area of expertise,
it mobilizes shame.
It allows for diplomatic pressure.
It allows for sanctions
and other kinds of pressure
that don't rise to the level of violence,
but nonetheless make it very uncomfortable
for tyrants to sit
comfortably in their seats,
trampling the rights of the
people under their authority.
It also provides ballast and
enthusiasm for those that would
advocate ideally by peaceable
means, but oftentimes
necessarily by tense and
sometimes violent means,
to begin to prop that
tyrant off of his throne
and to put in place a more
responsible government
that's consistent with
the rights of the people.
But this is hard work, and
in religious communities
especially, the mechanisms
for change, especially in
hierarchical communities,
just aren't easily there.
It takes reformations.
Reformations have occurred in
the history of Christianity
since the third and fourth century.
It's not just a Protestant
reformation, reform movements
have been a perennial part of
Christian identity in the West
and some of them have turned
into violence, some of them
have resulted in huge
dislocation of people
and deprivation of
property and loss of life.
That's part of the process,
and unfortunately our
Islamic, Hindu, Buddhist
and other friends are
experiencing the same
things around the world now.
- What is the responsibility
on the other side,
that is looking at it
from the perspective of
the human rights advocates,
the people who sort of embody
all of the rights that we've achieved.
So in this interplay between
religion and the Western
notion of rights, what is
the responsibility of those
individuals and the law that
they represent to be sensitive
to what's going on in these
religious communities and to be
respectful of where those
religious communities are
even as we would desire
change on their part
to come closer to the mirror
of human rights values.
- There are two pieces to that.
One is, what obligation befalls
the democratic human rights
revolutionary in the first
place, regardless of the object
of his or its or their or her advocacy.
And I would say there we have,
I think Martin Luther King
is a shining example, who always
insisted that the first way
to advocate for human rights
is to live them yourself.
And not to violate the
human rights of the other,
including the tyrant on the throne,
in the name of some cause that ultimately
betrays the very thing that you're doing.
You've gotta respect basic
rights of other people,
including the enemy, including the other
whom you're trying to displace.
I think that's a lesson
that's really powerful for
human rights advocates in
general, as they press for
democratic revolution, to
try to do this with as much
deference to the universal
claims that they themselves
are trying to make in
the particular moment of
the people that they're going after.
I would say especially with
respect to human rights
advocates looking at
religious communities.
I think we have to avoid
the easy assumptions
of the 1950s through 70s
where it was assumed that
religion is irrational,
that religious communities
are simply bastions of power,
themselves are simply incapable
of being reasoned with
on human rights terms, and come
to realize that human rights
communities historically,
and human rights communities
potentially still today and
in some places in reality
still today, are bastions of human rights,
they're zones of liberty
that provide opportunity for
revolutionaries, they provide
many of the basic what we call
second generation rights
of education and healthcare
and artistic opportunities and more.
And that religious communities are allies,
not enemies, in the
struggle for human rights.
There'll be hardened,
sometimes intractable religious
leaders out there periodically
whom one will encounter,
some of them will betray
the caricature that we have
of religion in general, but I
think folk have to recognize
that if you can find ways of
appealing to these religious
communities in and on their own terms,
find ways of making this human rights
mirror something that
they're forced to reflect on.
Your own canon says, your
own tradition teaches,
your own prophets have
articulated, your own great
traditional heroes have
spoken to these issues
in this particular way, and
to allow those folk to be
betrayed by their own religious
traditions and teachings
rather than simply having human rights
imposed on them from outside.
I think that is in many
ways the strongest advocacy
and most effective revolutionary move that
human rights advocates can make.
- Let's look at a case
in point, and that is the
growing number of Muslim
communities in the West.
The question is raised,
well, to what extent should
Western courts recognize
Sharia in court proceedings of
Muslim courts, and so on,
so what, give us a sense
of how you see this tension
evolving over time in a way
where there is appropriate
adjustment on both sides,
for bringing these communities together.
- Yeah, this is really the
issue just over the horizon of
the frontier of family law,
of religious freedom, of human
rights and of the place of
Islam in Western societies.
The question is, is to what
extent can faith-based family
laws, Sharia courts, be given
jurisdiction or power over
the marriage and family lives
of their voluntary faithful?
It's an issue that's getting
pressed very very firmly in
western Europe and the United Kingdom.
It's being pressed with a
little less alacrity in Canada.
It's just around the corner
here in the United States.
Think of Oklahoma last year
just passing a law that says
hmm, no Sharia, thank you, here.
Nine states have that under advisement,
people are seeing this as the big issue.
So here's the question.
Marriage and family law has
transformed over the last
50 or 60 years in the United
States, in part through
due understandings of sexual
liberty, personal autonomy,
privacy, and the
institutional requirements for
what marriage is, or what a
proper domestic relationship is,
have dramatically changed and been thinned
compared to their traditional form.
And now marriage
increasingly is a private,
bilateral contract to
be formed, maintained
and dissolved as the parties see fit.
Sexual relationships outside
of marriage are perfectly
permissible as long as they're
voluntary and the parties are
consenting adults, and the
traditional range of sex crimes
that are out there, abortion,
contraception, adultery
and the like, are increasingly
becoming private offenses
at best, that are not
enforced in part because of
dead letter or constitutional
change that's emerged.
Muslims don't like these
changes, for the most part,
in their new Western host
homes, and they want out.
They want to be free from
this marriage and family
law system that now obtains
in many western democracies,
including the United States,
and they want to become
a law unto themselves.
And their argument increasingly
is to say, we would like to
have our voluntary faithful
opt out of the state law
and into the law of our
own religious community.
And we would rather have our
imams and our Sharia tribunals
and our religious
leadership in our community
govern our questions of
marriage, family, sexuality,
child custody, inheritance and the like,
rather than have these questions
be dealt with by the state.
And if we have our voluntary
faithful who accept our
jurisdiction over marriage,
we don't want any one of them
appealing to the state when we
judge against their interest
and they all of a sudden seek relief from
a local state or from a federal court.
Their argument is that we'd
like to have that autonomy.
'Cause actually Jews have that.
They have their Halakah,
they have their Beit Din.
Christians have that, they have
their Ecclesiastical courts
that deal with marriage
and family questions,
and we wanna have that, too.
And if you don't like those two examples,
native peoples, traditional tribes,
they have their tribal
rulers, they have their
ancestral laws and they operate
their own legal systems.
And we want that autonomy, as
a matter of religious freedom,
as a matter of personal
autonomy, as a matter of basic
individual rights, equal
protection, due process of law,
and as a matter of simple
cultural coexistence
or multiculturalism, as the political.
The argument they're
pressing is an argument that
so far has gotten
nowhere in North America.
But that argument is
going to be increasingly
in the courts and in the culture wars
over the next 20 or 30 years
as Muslim communities grow,
as state laws of marriage
and family get thinner
and thinner, as different
forms of marital pluralism,
de facto or de jure are in place.
We have domestic partnership
arrangements, we have
civil unions, we have covenant
marriage in a few states.
We have traditional heterosexual
monogamous marriage.
We have same-sex marriage.
Why can't we have, in
the off-the-rack models
that the state holds
out, religious marriage.
That a party can simply take
that bundle of rights and
privileges that the state puts in place
and use those for their system.
That issue is gonna be pushed
over the next 20 or 30 years,
and I think we're gonna
have to develop resources
to start dealing with it responsibly.
- One of the things that
comes out in your essays
and also in our conversation here is this.
The separation of religion
and the law in the past
led to a kind of a general
misunderstanding, or a lack of
appreciation of the dignity
of the other, basically.
'Cause when one looks at
the issues, let's say in the
United States, where religion
seems to be a factor,
it's issues of gay marriage,
it's issue of abortion.
I think it originally started
in the question of busing
in religious school, so the
interesting problem here
is how do we restore a sense of the other,
and their dignity, and
where they're coming from,
as we prepare to argue
about which direction
the law should go in the general society.
And this then also applies
in the international context
where we, it's even harder
to appreciate what Hindus or
Muslims or whatever might want
because of their traditions.
- Yeah.
That's, again, a set of hard
questions and observations.
I think a lot of us grew up with another
school boy and school girl logic which was
strict separation of church and state.
That America's first amendment
teaches that there must be
a high and impregnable wall of separation
between the religious and the secular,
between religious or church
autonomy and what the state does
and the two should be
as separate as possible.
And political life, the public
square, laws, legislation,
laws by legislation or by
judicial decision making
had to be done free from any religious
preferences, premises, or preferences.
We oftentimes, both in our domestic policy
as well as in our foreign policy,
took that as a given about
how religion existed.
It was the private hobby
horse for the superstitious,
and it was something
interesting that they could do
and they had freedom
to do, but it couldn't
have any effect upon public life.
And we would suspect anybody
that made religious arguments
about legal and political
matters, and we would suspect
any politician that would
involve him or herself
actively in a religious community.
That's given us a reflex about
the purported secularity,
and the neutrality of law
and government in general.
And I think over the last
30 years, that's just flown
very very strongly into
very strong headwinds of
epistemology that have said,
come on, this notion of
neutrality really doesn't work anymore.
Everybody has basic founding assumptions,
meta ideals that they work
with, and that some of them
are religious, some of them are secular,
but they're equally fervently held.
Secondly, we've come from
that separation of church and
state logic into an
assumption that the state has
omnicompetence over things like marriage
or things like family, education, charity.
Religious communities may
want to do that themselves,
but the state really has
exclusive authority over this,
and a cooperation between
the two shouldn't exist.
And over the last 30 years
we've come to realize
with the pervasiveness of the
state's presence in society
and the activity of religious
communities in society,
that there are plenty of
areas where they overlap.
And so what the burden going forward is
is to find the places of
overlapping consensus,
of cooperation between the
two, where they can get along
and conserve each other rather than
being in constant tension with each other.
Whether that's a respect
for the dignity of the other
or the office of the other,
that's I think an aspiration,
but I think it's pragmatically at least,
religious communities
and political communities
are gonna have to figure
out how to get along
on some of the fundamentals,
both domestically
and then increasingly internationally.
And marriage and family questions
that we just talked about
a few minutes ago, education
questions, charity questions,
are areas where we're
renegotiating those boundaries.
And it's in this awkward business
of faith based initiatives
and this funny business
of religious legal systems
dealing with marriage and family,
that's the constant
renegotiation about the boundary
between public and private
schools, those are gonna be
perennially contested zones
of blurriness that happily
I think we have the mechanisms to continue
to negotiate day by day and over time.
And I think we're gonna have
to just get over the lie
that religion and law are
hermetically and hermeneutically
separate, and that religious
and political institutions
can live in completely separate
and distinguishable spheres.
The overlap is inevitable
in finding the hermeneutic
to allow them to interact responsibly,
maintaining the integrity of each side's
responsibility in society
I think is the goal.
- The tension here, it
seems to be on the one side
we can have fanaticism
and prejudice emerging
from one or another of the actors.
On the other hand, we see
things like humanitarianism,
charity, a fellowship
for the other and so on.
Is there an ideal lever
here helping us to move down
the right path to negotiate
these contradictions
between what can be the
dark side of religion,
which is a piece, that is
present in different places
and different times,
but on the other hand,
the real virtues and strength that are
brought by religion to the law.
- Yeah, I think the lever is
being constructed as we speak
and is being constructed
case by case, issue by issue,
area of competence by area of competence,
I don't think there's a
one size fits all for this.
Secondly I think it's
increasingly obvious that
the fundamentalists,
political fundamentalists
and religious fundamentalists
who are utterly dogmatic
about the certainty of their positions,
simply can't play in this
game, and need to be excluded,
and then that sends the
Constitution in the United States
through its establishment
clause, provides I think
very very strong support that
needs constantly to be there.
I think third...
No new cooperation between
religious and political
communities can betray the fundamentals.
The fundamentals of freedom
of speech and press and
assembly and association,
the fundamentals of equality,
on racial, gender,
culture and other grounds
that have been so highly sought after.
No cooperation I think
can sacrifice due process
and equal protection
ideals more generally.
And I think one of the
things that we've learned,
in part by trial and error,
is that as we think about
bringing religious communities
and political communities
back into cooperation, we're
gonna have to make sure
that we don't give up on those
constitutional fundamentals.
So in the faith-based initiative program,
to give an example, where
religious communities now can be
amongst others to receive
federal or state funding
and deliver that to the needy in society,
for whom the funding is directed,
those religious communities
can't discriminate
on any ground, religious,
gender, culture, racial
or other ground in
delivery of the services.
They can't coerce a person to,
as a condition for receiving
the aid, participate in their
religious worship service.
They can't use the...
Funds that have been directed
to them by the federal or
state government and divert
them to the support for their
religious worship or the collection of
religious obligations and the like.
There's a rather careful
set of boundary lines
that have been set, which
I think are healthy ones.
The education area is
another good example.
Yes, we can allow religious
schools and public schools
to sit side by side, and
that parties have a choice
where they want to send their children.
Or if their children are becoming
young adults, where they want to go.
But there are certain fundamentals
that are non-negotiable.
They have to get basic
reading, writing, arithmetic,
they have to have basic
physical education,
there have to be basic
facilities requirements
for laboratories and gymnasiums,
libraries that are there.
They have to have, they have to be
prepared as democratic citizens.
We cannot handicap them if they
choose to go to a religious school.
There, too, a religious freedom
objection or an argument
to say no no, we wanna
cooperate only on our own terms
by teaching them only Hebrew
or Arabic or Dutch or Latin,
simply is not gonna fly.
And there too I think we have
made the kind of pragmatic
adjustments, the construction
of at least one lever,
to make this cooperation work.
And those are hard things
to construct and they're,
it's a malleable
instrument that's gonna be
renegotiated from time to time.
I think it's worth constructing them
so that religious and political
communities can cooperate
with the outsiders, the
fundamentalist outsiders,
left out of that cooperative vehicle
and vigilant, vigilant,
transparent regulation
to ensure that the areas of cooperation
simply do not become stepping
stones for coercion or for
betrayal of some of our
fundamental Constitutional ideals.
- One final question, how
would you advise students to
prepare for the future where
whether they are religious
or not, religion will
play an important part in
kind of the public area,
the public discourse.
- I would go back to my
argument a few minutes ago about
the importance of learning to
train your peripheral vision.
Even if you don't wanna be
focused on religious life or
religious identity, you don't
wanna be part of a religious
community, that's taboo for
you, you've got your own faith,
you've got your own spiritualism,
or you have no faith
or you have anti-faith.
It's important as a learned
member of society to have
just enough knowledge of
those that have a different
set of beliefs and practices,
to be able to understand
what they're about, what
drives them, what are their
punch points, what are the
things that you have to
watch out for, and what are the things
within them you have to respect?
It's interesting, Mahatma
Gandhi has this wonderful idea,
a community and an individual's
commitment to freedom
is judged by how they treat
their most hated minorities.
And I like that idea.
It's basically a learned
citizen who's democratic
and who believes in human rights values as
a sine qua non for our
existence of living together
has to be able to know
enough to know how to,
not to love the other,
but not to hate the other.
And I would say for a person growing up,
to learn about different faith traditions.
To wander into a temple or a synagogue,
or a mosque or a church,
and kinda feel what's there.
To read a few of the key texts,
to be aware of what's going on in society.
So that you can be in learned conversation
and you can advocate the
position that you take,
which happens to be of
no faith or anti-faith.
If you don't have the resources
to understand the other,
you can't argue convincingly
about the other.
- On that note, John, thank you very much
for this fascinating discussion.
- Thanks so much for having me.
- And it was a great pleasure
to have you on our program.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(upbeat electronic music)